ونبقى مع اخبار تيك توك ومفاجاه بواجهها
في امريكا في مجموعه مشرعين امريكيه من
الحزب الديمقراطي والجمهوري قدموا مشروع
قانون لحضرتك الصيني بسبب مخاوف على الامن
القومي من التجسس واستنكار ما يقدم من
محتوى عليه والتشريع بيحضر التعامل مع اي
شريك التواصل في الصين وروسيا او تخضع
لنفود البيان حتى وصف ابقاء تيك توك بانه
بيشبه السماح للاتحاد السوفيتي زمان بشراء
نيويورك تايمز او واشنطن بوست مشروع
القانون هذا جيء في وقت فرضت في عدد من
الولايات الامريكيه قيود على استخدام تيك
توك على الاجهزه الالكترونيه الحكومه
ومنها تحديد السبع ولايات مثل ماريلاند
سوف طلع حتى حاكم ببيان منع فيه استخدام
الاجهزه الالكترونيه الحكوميه لتطبيق تيك
توك ومثل وشايفين في البيان بيبدا بعد
مستخدمين تيك توك في امريكا واللي بيبلغ
100 مليون مستخدم يعني عدد صراحه مو قليل
اصلا دونالد ترامب حاول في 2020 انه يحضر
تيك توك لكن خسر سلسله معارك قضائيه يعني
المحاولات هذه مو جديده في الطرف الاخر
كنا نرد على كل هذه الاخبار من شركه تيك
توك انه مثيره هذه الامور كلها مثيره
للقلق ووصفت المحاولات بانها مدفوعه
السياسيه
ولن تعود بالنفع على الامن القومي